hello everyone and welcome to the Grand
Final of this year's first edition of
everything's Masters uh so you already
know that Magnus defeated Hikaru in the
finals this is now the Grand Final as
confusing as that is but it is the game
we are interested in it is a true true
positional Masterpiece uh and you guys
will enjoy this one if you remember uh
Magnus played Hikaru in the finals and
they had five games out of those five
games all five ended in a draw in the
fifth game Magnus uh had the black
pieces in Armageddon he outbid Hikaru by
one second and he was able to draw that
game as well which meant uh the the
match Victory but now this is the second
match and this is the first game of the
match truly an incredible one uh let's
see why that is so so Magnus uh with the
white pieces opens with C4 he goes for
the English opening we have Knight to F6
uh Knight to F3 and now Pawn to E6 for
those of you who don't know
um if Hikaru wins uh this match uh then
there will be another match because
Magnus already beat
beats Magnus they will play a third
match if not then Magnus is the winner
of the uh air things Masters the the
primary division because now they have
divisions if uh player from a lower
division uh wins like like Fabiano did
in his division he moves up into the
main division and then he will play with
the absolute best so they are doing a
very good job at gamifying chess uh so
okay Ponte E6 with knights the Knight to
C3 Pawn to D5 and now Pawn to D for a
standard Queen's gamma decline three
Knights variation D captures and C for
the sharp Vienna variation and E4 white
grabs the full Center and black grabs
the flank on the queen Side Pawn to E5
and now Knight to D5 this is all very
standard stuff nothing new here Knight
captures on B5 and now Knight back to B6
and standard uh for white is here Knight
the bishop to E2 but Magnus goes Pawn to
A3 uh not new but very uh very rare So
Knight to C6 and now Bishop to E3 there
is the game where Bishop T2 was played
Magnus goes Bishop to E3 and it is now
as of move 9 that we have a completely
new game
it's okay Hikaru continues development
Queen to D7 uh we have knighted to C3
going back because now if this Knight
moves the Knight on B5 will be
vulnerable tonight back to C3 Bishop to
B17 carrying the bishop on this
beautiful diagonal Queen to C2 and now
Knight the A5 going after that B3 Square
uh Rook to D1 and now Rook the B8 with
Bishop T2 by Magnus and the bishop to E7
and now you might expect all right
everything is nicely developed uh he
controls the center he's probably gonna
Castle now but nah and not really Pawn
to H4 this is how modern chess is played
of course Magnus now wants to push H5
and H6 uh create a weakness and then try
to exploit exploit that at some later
point in the game with Bishop to C6 and
pawn to H5 with Bishop to A4 going after
the queen and the Rook so now you have
to trade Knight captures we have Queen
capture Sunny 4 and The Rook the C1
Magnus says alright you can trade here
but I'm gonna get my Rook to C2 my B2
Pawn will be defended and I'm gonna put
extra pressure on that C4 Pawn so nice
the B3 Hikaru kicks away The Rook from
C1 Rook to B1 and now Queen to A5 with
check and now if you had to block this
uh you wouldn't really enjoy your
position but here as Magnus already
started advancing his path his H Pawn
King the F1 is the move to play the king
will be very safe here and you are now
free to continue pushing your Pawn uh
and here Hikaru should play something
like H6 it's not a move you want to play
and it is a weakening of The Possession
uh but uh what comes in the game doesn't
uh help him either he played Pawn to C5
which is a principle the reply you
already cost white castling privileges
now you want to bust open the center and
you want to attack the white king
however there is a particular series of
moves that allows Magnus to gain uh a
considerable Advantage
from this point on so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the absolute
best way to continue the game for Magnus
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
absolute positional brilliancy and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Pawn to H6 or you could
capture on C5 and then play Pawn to H6
doesn't really matter uh because it it
works both both ways so uh what do you
do now you can't really ignore this you
g captures an H6 you just know this will
cost you the game if you play this uh so
your choice here is G6 and that's
exactly what Hikaru played now comes the
captures on C5 and the point is uh what
do you recapture with if you if you
recapture with the Knight which is
possible then you allow an ID D4 and now
you're threatening this monster Fork
here against the queen rook and Bishop
and even if black stops this you're
gonna put a bishop on F3 still getting
control of this of the C6 square and
this will be very very shaky at best for
black so Hikaru instead played Bishop
captures on C5 he wants to trade Bishops
here but now look at this bishop
captures on C5 Queen captures on C5 and
now the move that makes it possible as
the bishop on E7 no longer controls H4
Rook to H4 and now you cannot defend the
pawn on C4 or you could but it will
probably cost you dearly like if you try
Rook to C8 of course uh White will
capture on C4 because now the Knight on
B3 is undefended let's say Knight
captures on C4 Queen capture some B3
Knight captures on E5 now the problem is
there's this queen to A4 check and now
how do you reply to this let's say King
D7 now B4 comes and you will have a lot
of problems
um uh playing this okay B4 is not maybe
an absolute must but you should always
throw it in your your pawns will be much
closer to creating a pass Pawn in the
future and also once the black queen
moves wherever you're just gonna capture
on E5 and then pick up the A7 Pawn
because the black queen will have to
recapture you're gonna pick up this Pawn
with check you will have to connect That
Bass pawns on the queen side and
excellent winning chances so it would be
silly not to include B4 here uh that's
uh that's the reason why Hikaru decides
uh it's not worth trying to save that
pawn because I'm gonna have to give up
the other one uh let's just castle and
hope for the best and now Magnus
collects his pawn bishop captures on C4
we have Rook F to C8 uh attacking the
bishop and basically forcing the trade
that followed Bishop captures on B3 uh
Queen to B5 check now attacking magnus's
Queen so Magnus has to block with Queen
to E2 we have Queen to E2 now Queen
captures on B3 we have rooked the B4
attacks the queen queen to A2 and now
hoping to get A5 and A4 in uh sort of to
control the two strong pawns on the
queen side Rook to D1 and now Pawn to A5
attacks The Rook Rook B5 and pawn to A4
and here uh okay for the moment Hikaru
is controlling the two uh Queen side
pawns with Queen to E4 by Magnus uh now
uh putting pressure on the A4 Pawn as
well if the knight ever moves with Queen
to C4 check Hikaru forces a queen trade
and okay Queen captures Knight captures
Rook captures NBA Rook captures and now
Rook the D4 here uh Magnus is up upon
and you will see just how how uh well
perfect Magnus uh plays this out uh and
makes use of that pawn because it's not
easy to push those pawns he covered
blockaded the uh he he does have a two
to one disadvantage on the queen side
but he nicely blockaded the pawn and he
is attacking the B2 pawn and it seems
like he should be okay but Rook D4 is
such a monster move uh the the problem
is uh you you can't really do anything
if you play let's say you play Knight
captures on B2 which is possible uh King
E2 how is the knight ever getting into
the game there there's no way for this
Knight to get into the game you can't go
here you can't go here you can go here
you can't go here you can't move the
Rook from the back rank otherwise you
get to checkmated so this is is very
very close to a complete sukswang so
instead after Rook the D4 he car plays
Rook to C8 he had a rook captures is
also impossible because just Rook
captures on C4 so Rook to C8 and now
Rook to D7 now Magnus shifts his
attention to the F7 Pawn he's gonna play
Knight G5 and go after that weakness uh
Knight captures on B2 Hikaru has nothing
better now comes Knight to the G5 and
The Rook to f8 Hikaru has to go into
passivity with with his Rook here now
again Rook to D4 very important uh
keeping the Knight where it is now The
Rook is controlling C for D3 and D1 and
the Knight has no squares
so Rook the C8 The Rook can move once
again but now Rook to F4 attacking the
the F7 uh Pawn here and the problem is
that there's no good way out of this if
you if you play Rook to f8 then again
King the E2 takes away the the D1 Square
from the Knight and again this is now
complete the Knight has no squares if
the Rook moves lose the F7 Pawn if the
king moves you lose the F7 Pawn uh
there's no move you can make play F6 or
F5 with just e captures and F6 Alpha
song uh this is uh this is resized you
you would not want to be in this
position so instead Rook to C1 check the
only other option uh left for hikar with
King to E2 Rook to see to check King to
E3 Rook the C3 check King to D2 and now
the Rook again uh well is left with very
few choices if you capture the pawn then
Rook D4 how are you stopping Checkmate
you have to play something like King f8
then you lose this Pawn with the check
and then the Knight moves then H7 h8 and
it's game over so after King to D2 Rook
C7 was played keeping an end at F7 Pawn
but now finally Rook to B4 attacking the
Knight and uh the Knight now has to move
and give up the A4 Pawn Knight the C4
with check King to E2 now Rook the C8
you again have to stop Checkmate and now
Rook captures an A4 now the past Apon
has been created once again uh Knight
captures on E5 and now Rook to A7 again
putting pressure on F7 and preparing to
advance that pass Pawn so Knights the G4
and just a calm Knight captures on F7
you don't have to worry about a move
like Rook to C2 check because even if
you go after the pawns Knight captures
an F2 just Knight G5 and uh look at this
again not that Arrow obviously uh
Checkmate is being threatened and if you
go back Rook to C8 Knight captures an H7
Knight F6 check again it's a game over
so after Knight captures an F7 Rook to
B8 was played Now Pawn to F3 uh leaving
Kikar with zero counter play Rook the B2
with track with King to D3 now the pawn
is completely relevant now you have to
check King the D4 Rook to D to check
King to E3 and now Rook to A2 you are
out of useful checks now comes Knight to
G5 threatening Checkmate and here Hikaru
played Knight to D1 with check but also
he was in this position and move 50 that
Hikaru Nakamura resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here I
want the king escapes check lets the
king to D4 you can deliver a few more
checks let's say another check here King
F6 uh that's it it's made on the next
move okay in two moves because black can
give up The Rook but that's pretty much
it uh so yeah uh very very nicely done
by Magnus he won the first game then
games two and three ended in a draw and
game four also ended in a draw even
though Magnus was in a completely
winning position uh it's important to
win the match not that the game's here
so he accepted the draw in a completely
winning position which uh I I understand
that some of you I don't appreciate and
I don't appreciate it either but it is
uh important to win the tournament so in
that position of course everyone would
do that it's not like it's a game and
then you want uh like you know future
generations to Marvel at this game okay
you got a winning position you uh you
you accept the the win in the tournament
uh a reasonable thing to do
uh because you know there's very little
to win there and there's a whole lot to
lose uh so yeah uh that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it absolute brilliant
see by Magnus uh after this C5 move uh
there was nothing for hikar to do this
uh idea of of H6 characters and Rook to
H4 uh forcefully winning the pawn uh and
just uh you know enjoying your two to
one Pawn advantage on the queen side
absolutely stunning uh so yeah once
again hope you guys enjoyed it
um uh Hikaru fought well but uh I mean
out of nine games uh eight ended in a
draw and Magnus only got one win so that
is a well well a very well fought match
uh so yeah once again really hope you
enjoyed this I would like to thank
Carrie Smith Marcus grebel bocho uh
Kenneth Fraser and uh the the barcas for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of uh well everything that's
happening in the Chess World and uh
checking up in your wonderful
suggestions uh thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day